this is a guide for those of you who
were in a similar position to me when
the game mode first came out I am far
from claiming to be a top Tier 1 player
but I put quite a few hours into it at
the beginning just so that I can ensure
that I was able to complete it each week
for the comms that hidden behind it
you see this really isn't my type of
game mode but those sneaky devs shoved
in a reward that players like myself
will do our best to get a hold of
so this video will be about how you can
jump in as a solo player clear the rooms
beat the Nemesis wait a week rinse and
repeat
by now if you're watching this I'm sure
you've given to Santa go and probably
understand the basic mechanics so won't
dig into these too much
firstly you need to grab a weapon and
skill ideally I like to start with a
decent rifle they hit hard on these
earlier enemies and are a great way to
conserve ammo which can certainly be an
issue earlier on and this footage I
wasn't quite so lucky so instead I
picked up an assault rifle this isn't a
bad choice I may just need to purchase
some ammo in between rounds
as far as the skill goes if you're
really lucky you'll get something like
the striker drone this makes every room
up until the Nemesis super easy I've
only managed to get this once but it
made the room so much easier to play
through however you can't use it on the
Nemesis it just ends up being hacked and
turned against you
when choosing your first skill grab
something that will help with the type
of waves you'll be facing coming through
the predefined doors the Firefly skills
something I'd never use in the main game
are fantastic
ideally you'd want something that can
almost take care of a door on its own
while you focus on the other one
unfortunately in this run I wasn't so
lucky I ended up with the burst of
firefly still not a bad choice but not
as good as many other options
the first couple of rooms can be a
little rough you don't have any talents
you only have one midkit and limited
ammo and you're probably using a weapon
you hate fortunately the enemies are
weak but so are you
you are given 10 seconds to find a
position and get comfortable you should
use this time to find both doors
once located choose the door with the
best cover and take position
if you are unable to find the second
door take cover ensuring that your back
isn't too exposed
this just means you'll need to keep your
eye on the minimap to make sure you
aren't being flanked in later levels
there are more than two doors and you
won't know which ones they'll be coming
out of but since this guide is more
about getting to the Nemesis you
shouldn't see too many of these
in the perfect situation the aim is to
take up the hostiles at the closest
store before the second door is even
locked onto you if your cover is good
there should be plenty of time
alternatively you can use grenades as
this is a pretty easy way of clearing a
spawn but you only get a couple of these
however hopefully unlike myself in this
footage you'll have a skill that can
slow down one door while you take care
of the other
this may all seem very obvious but
honestly 95 of the reason you'll die in
these rooms is because you haven't
assessed the situation properly
beforehand it may have chosen an
adequate cover
I think this is where a lot of people go
wrong
think about what you're aiming for it's
all good and well clearing the floors up
until the Nemesis but there are a huge
number of talents that will be
completely redundant during that round
yes you may need some talents to help
you get through to the Nemesis but the
bulk of the talents you choose should be
focused on killing the Nemesis itself
for example any talent that requires a
kill to be activated is completely
useless
the way I look at the Nemesis is that it
hits super hard and has some fairly
decent armor my goal is to stagger it
and then mow it down before it can even
inflict damage on me so when it comes to
the talents I'm looking for raw damage
that doesn't have much in the way of
prerequisites to activate
at this point in the run I have no armor
and I'm feeling squishy as hell so I'm
using all the cover that I can and this
is where talents like composure and
OverWatch come in
other talents like vigilance and precise
are also super easy to activate you can
even get a lot of value out of bread
basket and Optimist but personally I'm
trying to stack those first two to four
as high as I can three four five Stacks
you're starting to hit some good DPS
with very little work on your part
this isn't to say that I'm ignoring blue
and gold talents altogether adrenaline
rush is one that saved me countless
times and descent if you can get this
leveled up two to four times you're
doing well
the gold doubts are probably the least
important to me but there are a couple
that I'll take it a pinch extra magazine
size is always useful so I don't mind
Lucky shot but also trauma which I'll
usually end up with I like this because
it adds a stagger on headshot which I'm
sure you can imagine is quite useful
with the nemesis
obviously RNG is a little bit of a
factor with the talents but you always
have the option to re-roll I wouldn't do
this more than twice because it gets
quite expensive but don't feel bad
spinning your credits every time you get
to this point if nothing you want comes
up
in this run I had a few times where I
kept re-rolling and wasn't getting
anything I wanted so I had to skip
meaning that it would have less talents
when I finally met the nemesis
after choosing your talent you're given
the option of picking the next room you
tackle now personally I'm trying to get
to the Nemesis as fast as possible so
I'd pick all easy rooms if I could
because of the higher Nemesis heat
percentage gained easy will get you
there the fastest technically this would
mean that you have less talents than if
you had taken on more of the medium and
hard rooms but I don't find the expert
challenge necessary
as the rooms actually start to get more
difficult after Loop 5 and I can't be
bothered dealing with that if I don't
have to however I'm still searching for
certain talents so rather than picking
the Next Room based on difficulty I
choose based on the proposed Talent
Rewards
the end of the loop presents you with an
arena as sort of a Boss Wave I tend to
play these pretty safe the high value
target has a lot of armor and can hit
surprisingly hard plus there is usually
a couple of waves
so in contrast to the way that I play
the standard rooms I'd find somewhere
that's easily defendable from range and
pick them off for the rifle or assault
rifle you'll notice some repetition with
the arena rooms so just find a spot
you're comfortable with and let them
come to you
once you've played the first Arena
you'll be given the option to choose an
exotic Talent I'm not really going to
cover these too much there are some good
ones like the lady death Talent
Chatterbox pestilence Outcast plague I
can't remember the actual names but
these really aren't too much to be
concerned about when it comes to
defeating the nemesis
after that you'll also be given the
choice of base stats to upgrade
much like the base game the noticeable
difference against a hard-hitting enemy
like the Nemesis means that I wouldn't
suggest putting anything into toughness
because remember our aim is to mow it
down before it's even able to react and
like I said earlier we're not focusing
on skills so when it comes to these
stats Chuck everything into offense
the completion of the Arena marks the
end of the loop you are now sent back to
the hub to restock upgrade and choose a
new weapon or skill
with any credits you have left over head
to the buying station get at least one
mid kit upgrade and then put one or two
into ammo
aim to upgrade the mid kits three or
four times before the Nemesis round just
in case things don't go to plan
the only other upgrade that I'll focus
on is the extending of the offensive
Talent slots a couple of times but you
shouldn't need to get these right away
next head over to the panel on the wall
and pick your next weapon I completely
ignore the skills unless you end up
getting some really bad weapon choices
my aim of the five to six Loops before
the Nemesis round is to have a decent
rifle and a shotgun like the sasg or
m870 but I'll take an assault rifle if
needed
the shotguns are just so strong in this
mode you can actually tank a whole door
without them getting a shot off you do
have to be careful doing this though as
the explodey dudes can really mess you
up
another situation where Adrenaline Rush
saves me
from here keep running through the rooms
in Loops collecting the talents you want
and upgrading your weapons be careful if
you end up hitting too many medium or
hard rooms this will cause you to head
into Loop 6 before you're able to fill
the Nemesis heat counter from here rooms
start to spit out multiple waves of
hostiles through the doors
[Music]
before the Nemesis round you are given
another visit to the hub you'll notice
two buying stations now because I don't
plan on playing any further after
completing this round I just spent most
of the credits that I have however there
are a couple of things you need to buy
first the Special ammo
in this case I put the firearms on my
assault rifle and the high velocity
rounds on my shotgun generally I try to
bait the Nemesis in after that you just
want to make sure you've restocked on
all your ammo mid kits and grenades once
you're satisfied you're good to go smash
that button to start the encounter
before I show you how this plays out let
me run you through the build I ended up
with this particular run
I would consider this pretty mid to low
tier in comparison to what you should be
able to get but in a second I'll show
you that this is still more than enough
Nemesis detected
system malfunctioning
simulation terminated
this was actually one of the longest
Nemesis encounters that I've had
recently usually I'd let it rush me and
I would take it down with around six
shots of the m870 but I was a little
trigger happy at the start there so I
had to use the assault rifle which took
a little longer but I guess this is good
because it shows the shotgun isn't nice
to have and isn't necessary
as you can see it's staggered almost
immediately from the first shot as well
as from its own grenade and then the
following fire rounds just continued
this the high DPS was too much too fast
so it never really had a chance to react
well this is where I'd usually jump off
because I've got my weekly Nemesis
project and around 10 to 12 watch levels
of experience in this particular
playthrough I kept going for a couple
more Loops just to show that there is no
reason why you couldn't just keep going
with this build
I'm sure there are tons of other ways to
do this but this has been consistently
working for me I don't really die to the
Nemesis at all anymore and I really only
wipe on the rooms because I'm starting
to get a bit cocky and end up putting
myself into stupid situations this mode
is actually less about RNG than you
think the ability to re-roll talents
removes a lot of this and there are
still a huge number of weapons that this
will work with I just did my personal
favorites
but if this guide still doesn't help you
with getting through the divs have
stated that they're looking at the
balancing of descent particularly for
solo players
I hope you found this useful and I'll
catch you in the next one cheers
[Music]
[Applause]